I told you about the time I got Beverly
Hills at the coffee bean in Beverly
Hills did I tell you that [ __ ] I think I
did that early on in this and one of
these episodes where I I was standing in
line at the coffee bean trying to get a
coffee and this Beverly Hills [ __ ]
woman who was like 60 70 years old and
looked like a [ __ ] mommy because she
got so much work done she came in and
stood in front of me in line she stood
in front of me in line how [ __ ] and I
said Oh ma'am I said ma'am that's by the
way that's the soundboard but I said oh
excuse me I was I was in line and she
goes and I said I I'm not joking she
said no you were over there and I didn't
even move I didn't even move I was
standing I watched her walk in and stand
in front of me and I said excuse me I
was waiting in line and she said no you
were over there and I said no I watched
you walk in I'm right here waiting in
line and she said oh no you weren't and
then [ __ ] caught me
I mean literally that happened and now
it was in Beverly Hills oh I get it
but also go [ __ ] yourself too cuz they
my head I made up a backstory about her
I'm like oh or a husband worked so hard
makes money and she's just [ __ ]
spending it even though that sexist that
was the [ __ ] I went to in my mind one
time I was looking at one time one time
I was looking at I was driving and I was
you know how you get in one of those
stairs where you're just like zoned out
I don't feel so good and comfy as [ __ ]
to just stare it like a leaf and you're
just hanging I'm talking about we're
just like this you can see on the video
pod but you're just like [ __ ] glazed
over and everyone's like and everyone
and and and and you're and you're just
like I don't want to get out of this I
hope no one bugs me and calls my name
because it feels so comfy so I'll car's
not gonna orgasm for your eyes
it's like an orgasm behind your eyes and
and I was doing that I was Paul I was on
in a Rhett on a red light at a red light
not on a red am i a Russian spy
there's only a red light no I was in at
a red light and I was just staring at
this Mercedes window and now it was so
tinted and and the windows were up and I
was just staring at this into space at
this Mercedes this really nice Mercedes
I guess I didn't know it was really nice
until afterwards but the window rolls
down like a crack which was if you're
gonna roll down a window in a car only a
crack and you didn't just get the car
washed whatever you're gonna say is
going to be the most [ __ ] [ __ ] of all
time rolled down the whole window if you
roll down a little bit and you're just
like and you're just like hey man [ __ ]
you know you're just a [ __ ] what are we
gonna say I'm not giving an example but
so the it rolls down a little bit okay
this dainty woman hand comes out with a
[ __ ] ring on it and she [ __ ]
flashes the ring at me like I was
checking her out now here's how you know
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] how you didn't
even pay for the car okay cuz you don't
know that the windows are tinted
you didn't go get the windows tinted and
you don't know they're tinted because if
I'm staring at a window that's tinted I
can't [ __ ] see if there's even a guy
or a girl in the car what if that was
the last [ __ ] I said and then I just
died it was a hundred percent tinted it
looked like it was paint and and I and I
was so taken aback dude that she had the
audacity to think that I was checking
her out through a tinted [ __ ] window
that my jaw drop now I was like a young
buck I was like 22 and I was like oh my
god like what is she doing I I actually
you know when things happen and then
years later you remember it and you're
like that couldn't have happened that's
what I [ __ ] feel like but I know it
happened so she she went like this and
waved her [ __ ] big-ass ring that
obviously her husband bought for her
because you
no and and after she drove away I had
the [ __ ] best slam of all time and I
didn't do it because I was so in shock
because I was a young pup now if you do
that to a 38 year old me and you do that
then I [ __ ] immediately clap back
with a [ __ ] oh I was wondering how
you got such a nice car because there's
no way you didn't pay for it awful
[ __ ] sound board - it came in
it [ __ ] grew it swelled it wasn't
even I should have picked why are they
[ __ ] dude she showed me her ring bro
you know how much that's the biggest ego
[ __ ] of all time oh he's checking me out
here's my ring I wasn't also you're sad
you cry a lot if you do [ __ ] like that